[Music]
one of the most aesthetically extreme
birds is the great Argus a kind of
pheasant found in Southeast Asia when
after Darwin wrote the Origin of Species
he was challenged by the Duke of Argyll
in a anti evolutionary tract to examine
the feathers of the great artists
pheasant which include these beautiful
golden spheres like a three-dimensional
optical illusion arrayed on the on the
wing feathers indeed Darwin spent a long
time trying to hypothesize how these
beautiful spheres could evolve from
intermediate States through the process
of mate choice in the coming century the
first person to ever see the first
scientist ever to see the display of the
argus pheasant was William Beebe he
travelled to Borneo where he spent
months studying the bird in the wild and
only getting occasional glimpses first
he found a male territory where the six
foot long male pheasant displays in an
area about the size of a quarter of a
basketball court he clears the the soil
and waits for a female well when bebe
built his first blind or hide right next
to the to the to the to the to the to
the display site the male abandoned
later he tried building a tree house
over another one and the male abandoned
as well in his third attempt he had his
assistants dig a foxhole in the ground
right by the display site and every
morning he got into the into the hole
and was covered up by with brush and he
spent all day hiding inside of a foxhole
and in the forest in Borneo after a week
finally a female visited this male and
he was able to see the amazing display
of the Argos pheasant in this case what
happens to the male opens his wings and
a raised his of his wing feathers like a
blown out umbrella creating a hemisphere
that that is suspended over
the female in this case the golden balls
on his on his wing feathers are
suspended in the air shaking and right
over the females head it's it's it's
it's an amazing and striking display how
could this have evolved well BB when he
looked at them noticed that the hend the
the the argus pheasant female was
basically stoic or unresponsive and he
wrote that it's clear to me that any
aesthetic impact of that display is
wasted on that little hen in other words
he couldn't imagine that she was having
the kind of aesthetic experience that he
was of course he'd been spending months
in search of this bird and in a week
sitting in a hole in the ground
he's having a religious experience right
but he imagined that the bird should be
dramatically moved but I think he got it
fundamentally wrong in fact behind every
evolved ornament in nature like the
argus pheasant display there's an
equally elaborate and co-evolved
cognitive concept about what is
beautiful the better way to imagine the
female's behavior is like a connoisseur
or art collector at an art exhibition
how do they regard this new art well
critically with some with some some
discernment right and this is exactly
the the attitude of the of the great
artist female right because she threw
her choices is really responsible for
the elaborate evolution of those
ornaments now is the display of the
great argus an honest signal of male
quality or merely beauty happening it's
an interesting question that still isn't
resolved but I believe that there are so
many dimensions to this ornament that it
is unlikely that it communicate quality
in this case all of the different golden
spheres they're there they're there
array over the female the the many other
elaborate details to the display each
one of them could
only evolved as an honesty as honest
indicator of quality if they were
independently associated with additional
information about mate quality and right
each cost would only evolve if it
provided information so I I think it's
extremely unlikely that aesthetically
extreme displays like the Argos pheasant
evolved because of honest advertisement
or adaptive while Lacy and mate choice I
think they're another fantastic example
of beauty happening
[Music]